i think the most burnout i ever got on
youtube like
because we can get into like now later
on but but i remember when i first moved
to london
for some reason i because i was going to
london quite a lot to do voice work
so i was like [ __ ] it i'll just move
there um
because why not nothing better to do and
i moved there and i was making about
1200 a month total before tax
which uh no no not great
so you're making about 500 dollars well
yeah and my rent was like 600 pounds a
month
right council tax was like 100 pounds a
and then there was bills included so
well after all bills and tax was gone i
was left with like a hundred to two
hundred bucks
yeah like food yeah and stuff and i was
like oh
oh that's not good that's not good and
then do the math
yeah i was doing the math on my
spreadsheet and it was like you're
[ __ ]
you're absolutely [ __ ] um and so
that's just put in a spreadsheet formula
because out your [ __ ] conclusion
you're [ __ ] so that that first month i
moved there i was like i really wanted
to change my content up as well because
i was doing strictly like black butler
based
and i was desperate to get out of that
because i really didn't want to keep
doing that because i phoned out a
blackboard i [ __ ] started hating it
and the viewers were really obnoxious at
times as well and
um so i really wanted to make this
content work and as you guys know when
you
normally when you try new stuff on
youtube the first few times you do it it
isn't perceived well
normally people are a bit hesitant about
it at least it was quite drastic at the
time
for me at least so i started doing new
content and i was working my ass off
and none of it was getting views and i
was like oh
i'm going to go broke i'm not going to
be able to i'm in danger
my like i'm like yo these four these
next four videos
bangers hundred percent banged yeah yeah
this is my new content new me this is
where i'm going to turn it all around
yeah and then they all bombed so
hard and i remember like how hard are we
talking like i was averaging about
uh in uh 24 hours i was averaging about
25k
views at that time i got to have 30.
which is not
wait wasn't it i mean how many subs did
you have at the time when i moved to
london it must have been about 200k
okay okay let's see i think i was
averaging anywhere between 25k
to 50k views of video in the first week
yeah which is fine
and i remember these all these these
videos all came out and they got like
8k and i checked like the ad rev and it
was like
15 and i was like i'm getting 15
a month for like from these videos i'm
gonna go [ __ ]
bro yeah and then [ __ ] amino come
down being like hey you want two hundred
dollars for a sponsored video
i i i have like no [ __ ] choice but to
take it
because i'm good i'm actually gonna like
be homeless if i don't take it
or i'm gonna have to ask my my mum for
like hey mom can you spot me
i don't want to do that yeah i don't ask
my parents i love how amino is every
man's first sponsor
because they they they [ __ ] rip you
off yeah
i remember they were they were my first
ones they know how to slide in yeah yeah
because that whole tactic is going after
channels that have like
are up and coming yeah that don't know
anything yeah yeah because i know i know
they gave people
who gave them up million view videos for
15 bucks yep
what 15 bucks because they don't know
any better
it's crazy genius it's just genius
it is genius slimy completely slimy
100 genius yeah and then luckily
you know those videos later on started
to like you know
i started turning it all around maybe
three or four months later right and it
started to really pick up the new stuff
and started getting an audience but man
those three months where i wasn't
picking up with the scariest three
months of my life
oh yeah yeah because i thought i was
gonna like i mean okay
i've never tried super [ __ ] hard at
something in my life and failed
yeah i thought like [ __ ] i'm a winner
because i'm i'm [ __ ] psychotic when i
want to get something done like i was
working like
i think stoic is the word you're looking
no psychotic
i was a [ __ ] girlfriend i was
psychotic i was like a relationship
vlogger bro i was on full psychopath
mode bro
i was working easily like 12 14 hours a
day
to get this [ __ ] working right i didn't
have any time for video games because i
was like i need i need to make this work
yeah yeah yeah but
and like it just wasn't working and i'm
like what am i doing wrong and then it
was probably probably because i was
probably too invested and it probably
didn't help right yeah because i felt
that every single video i was gonna make
could make me [ __ ] homeless if i
[ __ ] it up
yeah um so it was like [ __ ]
not only do i am i overly invested in
this
because i i really wanted to succeed i'm
also
gonna go [ __ ] homeless i don't get
this [ __ ] working yeah
and it's like you see i see it with
streamers as well when they're like i'm
a stream 12 hours a day and i'm like
that is
bruh i don't i don't know how streamers
do it man street
streamers is a skill set that i could
never understand and i could never do no
matter how much i
tried i think it's your personality
though it has to because i think i could
if it was my job i think i'd have no
problem streaming eight hours a day
i would have massive problems i don't
think i'd have yeah i just want to do
other [ __ ] like
i could do it but i'd prefer to do other
[ __ ] but i've very quickly noticed like
you know we talked about last week about
how
uh i've been getting into v tuber
streams and whatnot and i have a lot of
like spiral streamer friends as well who
yeah
like some of them can go like eight to
twelve hours a day no problems at all
i've noticed that like with streaming it
really is
like youtube where anybody can start it
but not
anybody can do it yeah like you really
have to be
built it takes years of [ __ ] up it
does
it does also the right personality